so girls weekend let's talk about your
man situation it's the furthest thing
from like maybe it's time for you to
step back into swimming feels well me
either
sorry didn't mean to scare you it's okay
I'm Ian I'm Cathy it's nice to meet you
Kathy do you want to join me
I don't normally what just two adults
that are attracted to each other
whatever happen it stays between us here
are your messages in Sepang Sullivan
before 8:00 a.m. thank you this is a
fresh start new school new friends for
both of us have you seen the new girl
she's the principal's daughter hey
what's your name um Bri we should hang
out more
us new kids have to stick together did
you have a good time yeah did meet a
cute guy I want to get some Ilya David
why are you being so friendly to me I've
been feeling we have a lot in common I
would prefer it if you didn't spend any
time with him you want me to stay away
from the one person who's gone out of
their way to be nice to me oops we're
gonna make her pay for what happened I'm
gonna get revenge for the both of us I
made a big mistake at the hotel that
night and I don't know why but he seems
to be targeting breathe stay away from
my daughter you want to lay your cards
on the table officer please escort him
off this campus you're gonna regret this
did Bri go home early she's Marcus
absent
looking for your daughter Cathy she's
got free I want to protect you you're my
little sister your mother own affairs my
father's heart dies I knew a car crash
they're arguing about your mom know
you're dying to destroy our lives needs
sorry
things could have been some different
let her go time to make me shudder
[Music]
you